so Sean I now come to the most exciting
portion of the interview where I get to
ask my own existential questions that we
call the Fantastic Four or the
quintessential cuatro
[Music]
I think that if you have quintessential
it should be five questions
yeah
so alliteration is Trump by numerical
accuracy good you're you're the perfect
person to point out that error thank you
Sean
okay so now we're gonna break and do uh
these questions all right
these are questions I ask you about
existential meaning and reality of uh
yourself advice to your former self and
what you think is going to happen in the
future kind of loosely related to uh Sir
Arthur C Clarke's various laws okay the
first one comes uh down to the following
when you depart this Mortal coil and
you're one of the few physicists that
quotes from Shakespeare in some of his
papers uh I find that quite delightful
but as you spring forth at the biblical
ordained age for the righteous
120 years old the age Moses got to when
he failed to reach the promised land
what do you want to put in your ethical
will not your material will it's a
concept in Hebrew known as the Zava ah
it's basically the wisdom or teachings
you want to pass on not just to your
biological errors of which you don't
have any as far as I know we'll get to
that maybe but to your ideological
errors of which you undoubtedly have
millions around the world
[Music]
what advice ethically or wisdom based
would you like to give
you know it's always a I'm torn because
I don't think advice works but I think
it's kind of necessary to give it you
know I mean I think that advice doesn't
work because some wise person says
something and some other person goes oh
that's true I will do it that's not just
not that's the Paradigm but that's a
failure for how advice Works advice
works if and only if it inspires you to
think in a deeper way right like go well
you know maybe I don't agree with that
but I see why they would say that and
let me let me think about it and you
know maybe that's the advice I would
give
um there's lots of different things that
I think are true that my usual piece of
advice is to young people
um Don't Wait For Life to happen to you
just think about what you want your life
to be and go out and get it and of
course this is I'm preemptively giving
the advice that I would give to my
younger self because that's what I
that's what I think is important like
but I wish someone had told me like I
was very good at obeying the rules and
doing what I was supposed to do and
taking classes I was supposed to take
and things like that but I just you know
let the uh various parts of my education
my career come to me rather than shaping
them actively myself and I wish I had
done more of the latter
very good well um Sean you don't have to
answer this question
um but uh I'm gonna see if it's uh if
it's if it's not inappropriate to ask
you I don't think you guys have kids and
I'm wondering was that a conscious
decision is that based on anything again
if you don't answer it we don't have to
we can cut this all out but the fact
that you didn't have children or don't
have them is that was that was that by
by choice or or was it not
yeah no it's clearly by choice it wasn't
a mistake
biological uh impossibility Jennifer
herself is adopted yeah so that was
always a possibility
um but it so I actually just got asked
this question on a recent ask me
anything episode of mindscape and so I
did answer it I haven't gotten through
the whole catalog yet no problem but
what I like to do is distinguish between
this sort of a personal aspect and a
universal moral aspect right and I won't
go into what the personal aspects are
they're not that interesting but my
point is there's no Universal moral
aspect for us like Jennifer and I did
decide not to have kids but not because
we think that was some moral imperative
it's bad to have kids you know we're
anti-natalists or anything like that
it's mostly because we were busy and we
had things to do and the things that we
were most interested in doing did not
involve raising children we love other
people's children we think it's great
when they have them go for it I'm a
pluralist in having kids like I am about
many things I think that some people
should have them some people shouldn't
and everyone should respect each other's
choices
very good um okay getting back to the
Arthur C Clarke framed questions there's
a question that actually pertains to
your former desk that you had account
unless you brought it with you that
that's behind you looks too new to be
feynman's desk but um uh so Arthur
famously said any sufficiently advanced
technology is indistinguishable from
Magic uh and I like to tie this question
into
um you know kind of the movie 2001 A
Space Odyssey whether these primates
these proto-humans on the Savannah in
Africa and they come upon this monolith
and they kind of like hit it with a bone
and they do all sorts of things with it
but I want to ask you
um now to look deeper than 120 years
into the future into your crystal ball
and ask what would you put on a monolith
if it was sort of a billion year lasting
Time Capsule I'll remind you uh Feynman
answered this he would write the atomic
hypothesis
um what would you put in or on you know
besides a CD-ROM uh you can't put that
in but what it would you put to brag to
aliens or what ever finds US billion
years from now have a little Swagger
about Humanity what do you think you'd
put uh to Captivate the magic of our
technology
you know
[Music]
it's an almost impossible question to
take seriously I know what you mean I
know I know the story of Feynman saying
you know everything is made of atoms but
I mean was he just writing those words
in English is that going to be supposed
to be helpful to people a million years
from now uh that seems implausible so
probably you would want to draw a
picture of something I guess right I
mean you could draw a picture of the
periodic table the elements that might
be a good thing
um I would even better love to draw a
picture of the second law of
Thermodynamics or general relativity or
something like that but I don't know how
to get those across in a simple very
good picture so I think that Feynman
might have been right you know to think
about matter as made of discrete units
even though that's not fundamentally
true but it's a stepping stone to
understanding things better if I could
somehow get an abstract concept across
it would be something like conservation
of momentum like they talk about in in
the book I think that realizing the
universe can run by itself that left to
its own devices things would just
continue on at a constant speed that's
really what opens up modern physics
modern in the last 500 years I mean
modern uh and so that's the one thing I
would like to get across I just don't
know how to do it in a picture yes all
right very good okay you already
answered my uh Third Law Arthur C
Clarke's Third Law of the only way of
finding the limits of the possibles to
venture Beyond them into the impossible
that's the name of the podcast so we'll
skip to the final question uh which is a
statement that Sir Arthur made he said
when a distinguished but elderly
scientist states that something is
possible they are most certainly right
when they say that something is
impossible they are very probably wrong
I'm not calling you old Sean but um what
if anything have you changed your mind
on
um in your work or in life
foreign
[Music]
well let's first notice that this
statement by Arthur C Clarke is complete
BS
it's just equivalent logically to saying
anything is possible right it's not
really a very helpful statement and
certainly there's no empirical evidence
behind it it's just a way I think it's
that there's a bit of smugness
right yes and I think that Arthur C
Clarke is being smugged when he makes
that statement a little bit so including
this statement is yes exactly
um I've changed my mind on lots of
things you know I mean the existence of
a non-zero cosmological constant is
something that I changed my mind about
you know science is great for that
because
um you do change your mind uh you're
forced to by the data right
um I I changed my mind about
philosophical things I used to be a
moral realist I'm not anymore I used to
be utilitarian I'm not anymore uh I've
changed my mind about what are
interesting questions in physics you
know because you do have to I mean
interesting questions are ones that are
not only one you want the answer to the
ones you think you can make progress
answering and I've learned a lot more as
I've grown in age and wisdom about what
I think I can make progress answering uh
so yeah all sorts of things and and I
don't even remember them because I'm
very good to just eat internalizing the
new wisdom and just pretending that I
was been like that all along if it
weren't for published papers I would
think that I'd never change my mind
that's right you can find Sean at
retraction watch everything
um so maybe the last question Sean if um
if money were No Object
um what would the mindscape project look
like what would your podcast look like
um what would your kind of um how to
change things besides you know your G650
um which I assume you're going to get by
proximity to the powers uh the halls of
power in Washington DC how would you
check how would the just focus on the
podcast maybe how would you do things
differently if you had unlimited funds
almost to dedicate towards this project
that's exactly what I was going to say I
mean the bottleneck is time more than
money
um you know the spirit of mindscape has
always been uh
uh a shoestring budget
it's you know I'm not going to put too
much time or money into it I did you
know splurge on a nice recording device
and some nice microphones
um and I realized you know that now that
most of my interviews are remote it's
very hard to control the guests audio
you know that's a that's a whole thing
if I had unlimited funds I would promise
to you know fly the guests to a real
studio and feed them caviar if they
would be interested in doing this and so
I would get much better audio quality
but otherwise that's mostly it you know
I think that the given what the spirit
of the podcast is money is not going to
be that helpful you know
um I would I would give back all the
money to the patreon supporters and and
not take ads I guess but like even the
patreon supporters you know they're
giving money I think that what they get
out of it as being part of a community
is more than like oh like an ad-free
version of the podcast you know and even
with the ads I get a lot of people
saying you know could you include links
to your advertisers on your website
because because some of them I actually
want you know and so I've started doing
that if you go to
preposterousuniverse.com podcast on the
sidebar I actually include links to the
advertisers where you can get your 15
off mindscape discount uh and things
like that so there's not a lot that I
would change I think it's a pretty good
system yeah no it's working very well uh
Sean I want to thank you and
congratulate you on a number you know of
of different items but especially on the
new book
um you know the biggest ideas in the
universe volume one space time matter
motion uh it's a wonderful accessible
book I'm actually using it for one of my
middle schoolers at home to learn about
calculus and that is a little Advanced
for him to learn about uh special
relative although he did have a lecture
from Jim Gates uh in person when I was
back at Brown on super symmetry uh but I
want to congratulate you on this book
which he followed it he got some some
good pointers I want to yeah
congratulate you on this wonderful
accomplishment and uh and the great
success wish you great success there on
the East Coast close to the halls of
power may you be a a physicist on a hill
there and influence the the country
towards the betterment of all mankind
thank you Sean so much my pleasure and
you know keep on uh the spirit flying
there in Southern California with the
surfing and the Sunshine which I know is
is your big deal so uh
thanks Sean bye
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from Magic
[Music]